another thing to ponder will be the
future of aaron rodgers with the green
bay packers or some other team he
created
a storm of something other than sand but
it starts with s and has four letters
with comments he made on sunday
following the nfc championship loss to
the tampa bay buccaneers he did it no
one else did i wouldn't thought anything
of it if i didn't see guys like jason
wilty of espn wisconsin and other
seasoned and tenured and experienced
beat writers covering the packers saying
on twitter whoa something's going on
with aaron rodgers it feels like a
goodbye that's how it hit our radar
screen so once it hit our radar screen
well i'm going to take
care to pay full attention to it and
develop it as much as i can and it
became a huge story on monday so shireen
aaron was on with pat mcafee earlier
today
and aaron rodgers addressed
the situation here's what he said i'm
going to read his quote
he said among other things
after the season i had
potentially winning mvp and obviously we
made another good run i don't think
there's any reason why i wouldn't be
back
but there's not many absolutes as you
guys know in this business to make an
absolute statement about something that
is not an absolute i didn't do it i
guess that's why it kinda went nuts now
look
he wasn't asked will you be back next
year he wasn't asked that question
and he's never been asked that question
per se and
i
i can't remember ever a time prior
to sunday in his career where he had
anything that was other than unequivocal
about his future
he veered into that topic on his own he
brought it up no one asked him will you
be back no one asked him do you want to
stay with the packers no one asked him
are you thinking about retiring to be
the full-time host of jeopardy he went
there
and
i look
i've got
i would say checkered is probably an
understatement of my history with aaron
rodgers i'm not afraid to criticize him
when he needs to be criticized or to
praise him when he needs to be praised
they tend to only notice the criticism
though shireen there's something strange
about a level of sensitivity that
certain athletes have but i've been
praising him a lot lately but i'll tell
you what i i think this is
i'd like to say the word i'll just say
bs from aaron rodgers to try to put the
toothpaste back in the tube this way
sorry aaron great quarterback i think
you should get a new contract i think
you do hold much more leverage than
maybe you're willing to admit and i
think what the packers did to you last
year was wrong but i also think it's
wrong for you to act like you didn't
like this fire you lit the fire and ran
away don't act like you didn't light the
fire don't act like other people are
making too much of it you did this
so to the extent that you're chagrined
or dismayed by the storm of something
other than sand but still has four
letters and starts with s has happened
over the course of the past two days
it's on you it's not on anyone else
number one mike as we said yesterday
everything that aaron rodgers does is
calculated so
a lot of quarterbacks might come in that
room and we say well was the heat of the
moment after a tough lot no
this is aaron rodgers it was well
thought out he knew what he was going to
say he brought it up on his own that's
number one
number two mike there have been
absolutes in every other postseason of
his career for 15 consecutive years we
didn't go on the day after the season
going hey what is aaron rodgers future
that was created when they drafted
jordan love either they have a plan for
jordan love to become the quarterback of
this team
or they have a plan to
create a jordan love trade scenario
where they can get additional draft
picks for them i tend to believe that
they drafted jordan love to take over
for aaron rodgers at some point in the
future
whether that was planned to be in 2021
2022 whatever but the the packers and
aaron rodgers created this whole
scenario of what is aaron rodgers future
by a drafting jordan love and by b aaron
rodgers saying what he said after the
game on sunday and i don't know that
what he said today changes anything does
he want more money does he want to trade
elsewhere does he want more say over
personnel and what they're doing in the
draft and free agency i don't know but
he needs to clarify that with the
packers when he meets with them later
this week mike
and i'm thinking back to his
press conference from
the aftermath of their blowout loss to
the 49ers in the 2019 nfc championship
where he was upbeat he was positive and
he said
i think we're gonna have one of these
soon in the future well
but nothing's guaranteed aaron there are
no absolutes how dare you suggest that
you will be back with the packers next
year when we know there's a chance you
won't be i so i just think there are
layers and layers of bullcrap on his
effort to say pay no attention to the
man behind the curtain the great and
powerful aaron rodgers has spoken i'm
not buying it and i'm entitled to not
buy it because again he's the one
unprompted that said there's a lot of
uncertainty with guys futures
myself included
just leave out myself included and none
of this happens what the hell does
myself included mean does it mean well i
could get hit by a bus tomorrow well
yeah that's always implied
but other than some sort of debilitating
incident keeping aaron rodgers from
either being alive or playing football
there's no reason for anyone or at least
there was no reason for anyone to think
he would not be back with the packers
he's the one that gave us reason to
begin talking about it and now he's
trying to act like well you know you
know uh come on it's j you know and i
mean the attitude was kind of like well
you know it's clickbait or it's you know
people have nothing else to talk about
ba
lo
knee it's on you you don't like this
it's on you not that it's some big deal
frankly i appreciate having the content
i'm not going to turn up my nose at the
content but again don't act like you
spilled the milk and now you're
wondering why there's a puddle of a
white liquid on the floor
and mike i've thought about this the
last 24 hours too say you're aaron
rodgers and you decide all right i do
want to go somewhere else i don't like
what they did with the personnel i want
to go somewhere else i can win i'm going
to demand a trade when you look at the
sean watson it's easy to look at all the
teams that would be an upgrade for him
to have a chance to go win a super bowl
to me when you look at aaron rodgers
there are very few teams that he could
go to that would be an upgrade over the
packers that would give him a better
chance to win a championship than with
the packers maybe you talk about the
rams and the 49ers because of the rams
defense obviously 49ers just went there
they're they're they had a good year i
think for what they did but if the
packers say absolutely not we're not
trained you to an nfc team you have to
go the afc you look at the colts yeah
that might be an upgrade but now you're
facing patrick mahomes josh allen and
all those young quarterbacks in the afc
that you have to go through just to get
to a super bowl i don't know mike that
there's a better situation for aaron
rodgers than where he is to try to win
another championship now they haven't
done it for a really long time we know
that and he only has one and he's
running out of time we know that but i
still think the packers and aaron
rodgers are a perfect marriage for
another year or two to see if they can
pull this thing off
and i think what he's looking for
shireen and i i heard last night from
someone i trust very much that aaron
rodgers wants a new contract and that
doesn't mean a gigantic raise it doesn't
mean he's underpaid relative to the rest
of the people in society but when you're
at 33 and a half million and deshawn
watson's at 39 million and russell
wilson's at 35 million and patrick
mahomes is at 45 million there's
something wrong with this picture oh by
the way the guy we're going to talk
about in a minute jared goff is also at
33.5 million and as we agreed yesterday
both goff grossly overpaid and rogers
grossly underpaid and they're meeting at
the 33.5 midpoint but
he has every right to want something
more than just money he wants
security and i've said that word pft
live this morning i said it yesterday
and i think people
confuse that with financial security i
know he's got financial security what
he's looking for at this point in his
career i believe because i would be too
is the idea that you're still all in
with me and
a new contract with significant
guarantees and significant cap
consequences arising from trading or
releasing aaron rodgers over the next
few years would give him
that peace of mind that he knows i can
go into 2021
knowing there's a 2022. i can go into
2022 knowing there's a 2023. see what
he's got to ask himself is how long do i
want to do this
and how long do i want to know that the
packers want me to do it he may want to
play until he's 43 well they're not
going to give him a contract that
secures his future for six years they're
not going to do it but his current
contract is secured for one more one
more that's it
after 2021 all bets are off they could
easily move on from him
no question we're going with jordan love
period they could do that i think what
he wants and i think what he needs and i
know what i would want need in that same
situation sharing is something that says
to me we're with you you're our guy this
isn't
we're going to run it back one more time
this is we're going to do it three more
times and then we'll see where we are
after that
and i also think mike that he wants the
commitment to the personnel to improving
the roster which he thinks they didn't
do in this past draft i mean he said
that with the drafting of jordan love a
quarterback who didn't help him at all
this year second round aj dillon came on
at the end and probably is going to be a
replacement for aaron jones next year so
he will pay off and and be a benefit
going forward but he didn't help him
much this year they need immediate help
if they're going to win another super
bowl with aaron rodgers that much was
evident against the bucks you have to
figure out how to beat the tampa bay
buccaneers which you couldn't do twice
this year if you want to get to another
super bowl because we know tom brady is
back next year
mike yeah and uh well we'll see how it
plays out from roger's perspective from
the packers perspective ceo mark murphy
was on the fifth quarter show on wnfl in
green bay here's murphy
explaining the packers position on
whether or not there are absolutes as it
relates to their desire to keep green uh
keep aaron rodgers with the green bay
packers
i'll say this
there's no way in heck that aaron is not
gonna be on the packers i mean he's
he is uh he's gonna be the mvp of the
league
might have had his best year ever he's
our unquestioned leader
and you know we're not idiots
and we're not idiots well then why did
you draft jordan love and why did you
give up a fourth round pick to go along
with the first round pick although look
i still think that this was an effort to
light a fire under aaron rodgers the
same way that drafting jimmy garoppolo
lit a fire under tom brady in his final
years with the new england patriots but
regardless we know the packers want him
we know the packers want him at least
for another year after 2021 that's when
they can decide we're ready to do
something else i think rogers at his
core wants more than that and that's
that's why whether he did it
deliberately or whether he just blurted
it out that's why the words myself
included were uttered because he's
getting closer to the point where he
doesn't know whether or not his future
beyond next year is secured it's not
about next year it's about the year
after next year
i wonder mike what the front office and
the coaching staff went into this year
thinking i mean did they have a thought
that
all right if we win the division and
lose in the first round let's go with
jordan love next jeremy was there some
thought of that of moving on from aaron
rodgers if they didn't do x it you know
was there a a point when they would have
moved on from aaron rodgers after this
year and i mean obviously i don't know
the answer to that but i do wonder that
if if they had something in their heads
of we'll be ready to move to jordan love
if
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports